I am
these men say they want to fight
Democratic Republic of Congo's Army says
they're among more than 3 000 people
who've responded to a call for recruit
I am here because we are suffering too
much my family my sisters they have
suffered a lot from war some of them
were raped so we're here because from
now on I need to defend myself everyone
here says they're ready to fight M23
widely seen to be a proxy of neighboring
Rwanda although Rwanda denies it 26
years ago Rwanda and Uganda invaded
Congo ever since they've been repeated
accusations of meddling and the presence
of foreign forces for most of that time
including sometimes from those countries
as well as U.N peacekeepers and now East
African Regional forces are arriving
here but there's a growing voice from
campaigners in Congo who say more
foreign forces will not be the solution
to Congo's problems
as M23 Rebels make advances patience has
run thin with un peacekeepers they've
been here for more than 20 years people
burn some of their vehicles in a convoy
passing near the eastern city of Goma
last week
people have protested in Goma and
Kinshasa in recent months against Rwanda
and Uganda who they blame for decades of
military aggression and against the
peacekeepers who they blame for failing
to protect them
Kenya says it's now sending troops to
join the conflict although only about 60
have arrived
it's the latest country to send soldiers
to Congo under the banner of a new East
African Regional Force
these activists say it won't help
they've raised money and bought food for
Congo's soldiers who are often short
supplied
replacing U.N peacekeepers with East
African Community forces is stupidity
the countries in the east African
Community are the same countries already
aggressing Congo we disagree with the
peasants of these East African Community
forces they say that we are with the
Congo's Army and nothing else
the Decades of conflicts have driven
tens of thousands of young men to join
armed groups many fighters have been
demobilized by the government in the U.N
Congo's Army says they're not among the
new recruits
this is the argument from our enemies
trying to destroy the image of these
recruits none of them are coming from
the armed groups all those from the
armed groups are in Cantonment in
another Camp none of them are here
Congo's Army defeated the M23 Rebels
nine years ago when it had supplies and
support from the government and the UN
people here are waiting to see if it can
do it again Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera
Gomer Democratic Republic of Congo